okay i guess we'd better start today i i
still i still see a few empty chairs
this morning it must be the day that
problem four is due
four is the one that uh we're trying to
solve has anybody
solved it what
no
no
amy no
marianne no cathedral
andy
okay well look uh uh
don't tell me that i finally stumped the
best minds in the world
on a problem here what's uh
do we have any partial results do we
have any i mean you know there's there's
the total result which says that
that you know exactly what the
uh
that that you need uh
a three to the
n minus something like two or something
as a minimum number of
configurations but what but does anybody
have any partial results saying if
you're going to get
a better construction than that then it
has to be of a of a certain restricted
form or something like that
i think neil modern thing's not
uh they were working the other night and
they thought they had a proof and then
found a bug in it oh oh well
i don't know if they've gotten anywhere
since then yeah i think anil decided he
should work on the portrait at this
point
yeah well there is that uh
i understand i understand that you have
an absolute deadline on thursday yeah
and this deadline was it was a little
less
firm
okay so uh
uh now let's see well i should try to
figure out how to play it then the rest
of this morning
at the end of the hour you're supposed
to do class evaluation and so i have i
can't just blow it completely
i mean although when you fill out these
forms of evaluation then
please remember all the other all the
other great times we've had
just in case i do blow it this time
okay um well i've got uh hmm no
so roger you don't have any partial
results anything anywhere didn't get
anywhere that's interesting okay well i
mean sometimes
i mean you gotta face we gotta face the
the uh prospect of
failure i don't know maybe you guys are
better at it than i am at giving up a
problem maybe
one of the things that happens to me
occasionally is that i work you know
that i just can't
uh get over the curiosity i have i just
have to know whether something is true
or frozen i forget to sleep eat and all
these other things
which has been bad for my uh
i mean
for my health etc it's almost as bad as
time sharing has been for my health
i i've had to stay up late using
to use computers when i couldn't get
good cycles during the day and stuff but
sometimes uh
well i think that there were
at least five times in my life when i
worked very hard on that problem and
finally decided
yes i'm not going to solve it i got to
give it up
and i'll never get it
and
three times i think of those five
an idea came to me an hour later
but i but i wouldn't have probably
gotten that idea if i had kept grinding
on it but i finally decided that i was
you know that i was gonna
that i thought that that there was no
way i was gonna go on i had to go on
with the rest of my life and so on
and i was prepared to give it up and so
several problems i have given up on
and never solved for example the
p equals np uh problem and uh
i mean once i thought i had had a four
page proof of that and i got to the
point where i'd written up the paper
proving that p was unequal np
and uh
it was time to write qed
and then i
realized i hadn't proved anything at all
i mean i i thought i was completely done
and all i had to do was write
and that proves the theorem and then i
realized that i had that that my whole
construction made no sense
so sometimes i just deluded myself and
and then you know so there were there
are times when i had to come to terms
with the fact that i wasn't going to
prove that p was unequal np
and uh similarly for a few other things
about deterministic languages and things
like that
but other times
somehow it seems that our subconscious
will go to work on a problem after we're
after we're conscious after after we're
we're done with it consciously and all
of a sudden
uh
uh middle of the night or something i'll
say wait a minute
because in this fit and then all of a
sudden it just yeah that the thing is
being crashed um i i have one i i think
um
uh uh
still we ought to add some footnotes to
what we did on thursday because there
are more powerful results than what we
what we did last thursday and this will
lead somewhere if not to the final
solution
um
uh then at least this is uh
there is a
there is uh
more to be said i think than we did
before so i better
mention that today and then if we run
out then if i run out of things to say
and if you run out of things to comment
on then i i could talk about half tone
fonts or something like that related to
the third two uh
portraits all right so let's uh let's
see now last week
we had a construction
that uh
that
showed uh
pretty good grounds for for believing
that if we had
three
um
two-state devices in the system we're
going to have trouble completing it
and
now i wanted to
examine that a little bit further
we started out on that time saying there
exists a good cycle and therefore
we got this construction of the alphas
and betas
that had to march along
now
i really haven't worked this out at all
but i've got some ideas that i think
should be
should be mentioned and maybe you can
see
also how it works um
uh in the first place
instead of
saying that
there exists a good cycle
um
we might stay if you start with any
arbitrary configuration
uh
then
if we
if we follow the um
if if we follow any any continuation of
moves from that configuration we
eventually get to a good cycle so that's
a slightly more powerful uh statement
and uh and and in fact we could just say
just take the leftmost sequence of moves
for example suppose that that if you
have a configuration and several
processors can move uh let's just move
the one that the the leftmost processor
uh
say in in a in a pattern and then see
what
and and we and that that defines a
unique uh
uh uh that he finds a deterministic
sequence from a
um
from a configuration furthermore even if
we take a partial if we have a partial
some part of a configuration in which
there's at least one baton at least one
one
one thing able to move
um
then we can we can look at what is the
the uh the left most uh
consequence of that configuration
uh so so we can
say for example if i have a string
if if i have part of a configuration and
say it's preceded by a zero state two
processor and a front and and and some
zero state processor at the right and i
have some
some uh configuration alpha here
uh
either alpha is stuck or it or it can
eventually uh or anyway
it has it defines a leftmost sequence of
of of states
of of moves so if alpha if any if any of
the processors in alpha can move at all
let's move the left muscle let's forget
about these zeros here let's not move
them in any case and i'll keep on moving
this until i get to alpha bar
which is the which is the uh the first
time in which
it can't move anymore
okay there's got to be some this is a
well defined mapping from alpha to alpha
bar for any for any processor uh and any
any uh two things in front of it i mean
any any any uh assumed states before and
after uh
saying always move the left most thing
you can in alpha and see what the what
the corresponding alpha bar is
so now that that
is some mapping from configurations to
configurations that might that might
help out in this
in this process
so
in other words
well we've got to know more than we did
last thursday and so the way to do it is
to find find a way to have a notation
for for the things that we're coming up
with i see a reef has just arrived have
you solved the problem
you haven't solved it you have partial
results
no
no okay well maybe your meal will show
up in a minute
okay
um
now
so let's uh
let's look at this this idea then
we could we could sort of
we could i don't know um this alpha bar
might be called alpha of zero zero or
something have some notation for for it
for for any for any
configuration and certain neighboring
states we have a a mapping as to what it
would what it would go to if we made all
the moves that we could
whenever there's a choice of more than
one
choose the left most say
um
now then
then we might be then there's a possible
chance of getting counter examples with
uh
with with that
okay now let's look at
let's look at um
the kind of things we had last time
uh but i'm going to write out explicitly
alpha 0 0 beta0 and and for the time
being i want to simplify the the uh
the setup of overlap over what we had
last time because again another idea for
for working on a problem we can't solve
is to say well let's
add an assumption or simplify something
and see if we can't solve a simpler
problem
and then then if we uh if we uh if we
can't even solve a simpler problem then
we're really in trouble if we can solve
a simple problem at least we have some
idea for what doesn't work on the more
complicated problem as well as what
might work on a more complicated problem
so we've got to simplify it down a
little bit so i'm i'm going to simplify
it down to the point where i have two
two non-empty
patterns instead of three so i'll assume
that i have a two two two state
processors and then i have between them
some undetermined number of processors
at least one and some undetermined
number of processors and their their
initial configuration is that is alpha
0p beta0
let me actually give myself a little
room here
and i'll say that we start out in this
in this situation
um
now let's see where was i um
uh so instead of three i put two and i'm
putting in the the zeros explicitly the
other assumption i want to make is that
that in a uh
that in in all reasonable things i want
to look at
the
uh the uh to the motion through a
two-state processor will always be to
the right
and so i'm not going to
i'm going to assume that i don't
back up once this
um
once i've gone through
uh so the first move was to here in our
assumed good cycle
and i'm going to assume that when i get
done
i get to
i haven't changed this one back to zero
again but i'm but it's still sitting at
one
now
um this is this is an assumption that i
can't make in general i have to verify
it later on but i'm going to assume that
as i
uh first of all i'm going to go back to
the idea then last week that we have a
good cycle and that the baton is moving
but i'm going to say that that once the
two-state processor passes the baton to
the right he never gets the baton again
until it comes to him again from the
left that's the
that's the assumption i'm going to i'm
going to make
um
and see if that
uh if if i can construct uh if if i can
show at least that it's impossible to do
it under these circumstances if we can
show that then we then we say well okay
maybe
then then the only possible
constructions are ones in which the
baton gets passed back to the two-state
processor and then we can see if that if
that helps us any but first let's
consider that simpler case
now that means that the reason that this
um
this has some effect because it gives a
parity condition zeros to zero always
goes to one and then on the next left
one goes back to zero and our next slab
zero to one again
this one then
we will finally get to a situation
where
where um
alpha zero has gone to alpha one and
then the next move is alpha one one
theta zero
now
uh and and this pattern continues
before i before i
go further than this i want to mention
we could also say
go to the notation i had a minute ago
saying if i have a 1 alpha 0 0
that this is and then i move the left
most thing in alpha 0 that i can
in general this will take me to a to a
alpha one
um
this will take me to a one alpha one
zero uh which is the first time that
that there's no more moves left
and at this point we get to this
so so in general we can assume without
it
we know without any assumptions that
that that this state that would
would lead us to that if we start with
this configuration we're going to have
to get to this configuration sooner or
later uh i mean if oh let me see there's
a sequence of moves that takes us to
this configuration after which somebody
else has to move alpha 1 is now stuck
alpha 1 it's alpha one is dead when it's
preceded by one and followed by zero
um now at this point then somebody else
has to move
and
in our good cycle if this was a really a
good cycle
beta0 was stuck when preceded by zero
and followed by zero therefore beta0
can't move alpha one can't move so it's
got to be either this one moves or this
zero moves
all right
now it now so now it comes time to make
my assumption that the baton is always
going to go to the right and so it's
going to be it's got it going to be this
one that moves that's we're going to
force it to go in here the other
possibility that we go from here to 0
alpha 1 0 is another
something else that i would explore
later but right now i want to always
consider the two state ones always going
to the right if anything
all right so at this point i get alpha
one
one okay then what happens next uh the
same kind of a thing occurs one beta
zero one followed by a one is going to
lead eventually to the first case where
the betas can't move anymore
and that we'll call beta1
and now for beta1 instead followed by a
one
um
okay
let's just try i'm thinking we see we're
assuming that this this was a good cycle
which also allows us to prove that alpha
to to conclude that alpha one followed
by one is dead
but
in
in the more general case i guess we
can't
do that okay then this will lead us to
then uh by the same argument zero alpha
one one theta one
and that will go then to
zero alpha two
one beta one
zero alpha two zero beta one
and
so on
beta 2
1 alpha 2
0 beta 2
and up up and then this will eventually
have to get into a cycle it'll be
eventually cyclic
uh
so the alphas will be equal in the
subscripts so on the alphas and betas
will be module or something or other
this uh
i want to go up up one from the from the
beginning position just to see what it's
like
so that would be the corresponding to
this one
so there will be a zero alpha zero
zero beta minus one
here
up up above in in the environment of
that
of that thing or eight minus one mean
meaning um k minus one where k is the
period length of p minus one anyway this
is the the way it'll look
in this uh situation then
which we know we know these alphas and
betas are going to exist uh
and if we assume this this this baton
noise to the right
uh in the in the two-state processors uh
we also
we also have this
kind of a pattern where where the office
have um
um
well the alphas have different uh
subscripts keeping on growing and
growing but i haven't
done any more now what do we know about
these
alphas and the and we know that zero
alpha sub two k zero
is dead
and zero alpha sub two k one
is dead
um
for example 0 alpha 0 is dead because
it didn't have the
it didn't move from here to here and
zero alpha
zero one is dead because it didn't move
from here to here
uh with the um
uh
and and on the other hand the odd in the
odd case
1 alpha 2 k plus 1
0 and 1 alpha 2 k plus 1
1
are dead
um now what about the other one then so
one alpha two k
like one alpha zero zero
this leads to
um
one alpha one zero one alpha two k plus
one
zero
and one alpha sub two k
one
is unknown
i don't know what happens to that one
but
it it can uh
well yeah we don't
almost anything can be
happening we haven't got that hasn't
arisen in in the uh in the cycle
um similarly here we got zero
alpha two k plus one
so zero alpha one
one
leads to
zero alpha two k plus two one
and
zero alpha two k plus one
zero
is unknown
um yeah john i don't quite see what you
can get by having four processors
because there's obviously the
case where the alpha and beta are two
state
yeah that's right we'll there there is a
there's a case when
which will actually uh arise uh that
that works with with two-state
processors that's correct
so so uh um but somehow we'll have to
that'll force us maybe into a
into a um
um
sort of there's only one way that can
work and so that'll force us into uh
into a higher level consequence of this
which then would have to be true if we
went to
if we went to four for example if there
were really six we could absorb it and
call it two and four
and then
and then we know something about these
four
maybe and similarly we could call it
four and two and then we know something
about these four and then we might be
able to combine that i mean i i have no
idea but but first of all i wanted to
see what what we can prove about the
about it from this level right yeah but
your point is very well taken that i'm
not going to show it's impossible i'm
not going to definitely come up with a
uh
uh
there has there's at least one way out
of this mess isn't there
and it must be because of these question
marks here
in fact in the
in the uh
in the case of uh 16
things
yeah um
okay
now
um
one of the things that might be true is
that the period has to be
fairly short for example
um
in in that case i mean maybe maybe the
period you know let's call this p for
period
maybe the period has to be
4 or 8 or something
now
but let's try to find as many
consequences as we can
of the of these uh primitive axioms and
we have more things to check
now let's see
one of the things we can conclude is
that p is even
do you do you see why that is
compare what what happens with a 2k and
a 2k plus yeah because if you were odd
then these two then a
alpha 2k
would also have to equal alpha sub 2 j
plus 1 for some j because there would be
you know it would uh and
it would it would the evens and odds
would get mixed up and and uh
we do have uh uh case that this one is
dead and this one is alive
uh
so
uh like so that's a contradiction so so
uh
we we we know that p is even
small theorem okay we take anything at
this point
okay now um
now the next thing is uh
let's look at
let's look at what happens if we start
out with zero alpha
sorry 1
alpha 2 k
0
beta 2 j minus 1
where j and k might not be equal
well
in this this is a situation
like we had on the board on thursday
where we wanted to try to get a com
a counter example
and um
this is a
case where we have two things can oh i i
didn't write the uh the laws for betas
um
and uh the laws for the betas are
exactly the same as the laws for the
alphas except the right most bit is
complemented
and so for example
one beta zero one is what we know
because one beta01
is what we know goes to to the next case
it's not one beta zero zero so that so
when you have a beta here you you you
have to complement the the the value on
the right neighbor
that's too bad it's for decremental
subscription data
you say that even not are different on
the bait i don't think that's true
well because you're because the zeros
it's going to be for example it's going
to be 1 beta
you're not considering this is just a
substring of a substring of process this
is supposed to be the bleak ring you've
got on the board there
okay yeah okay yeah it's this is a
complete this this is followed by
the next one so the one the one on the
right has to complement its right input
as far as the laws that satisfy that
concern
um
so zero
followed by an odd data
followed by
a1
would would use the same thing for zero
followed by
an odd
way
it's interesting
one alpha two k zero
zero
beta
see do i have i'm seeing if this checks
with my other notation i'm confused here
sorry
one
that's okay one
zero
okay maybe i just wrote it down wrong
so if i have a zero followed by an odd
beta
then that followed by a zero
then i then i know what it happens but
here i don't i really don't know what's
what's going on in this side do i
okay well
so like so i don't know what's what's
happening here
um but i do know that this can that this
one can take can go to to 1 alpha 2 k
plus 1
0
beta 2 j minus 1.
now let's see
so at this point
okay this differs from my it's different
from what i thought was true
um
at this point they the alpha 2 k plus 1
is dead in between here beta 2 j minus 1
preceded by zero followed by one i don't
know what it'll do
but let's see it is
um
let me write out what i know about 0
beta 2k
2j minus 1
followed by 0
goes to
oh gosh zero followed by goes to zero
beta two j
zero
alpha two
okay
that's not the case i wanted to consider
um
we'll get into something like this in a
minute but let me try let me go to this
one i think that's the this one
this is the kind of thing that i really
had in mind i think when i start started
out um i i got
one alpha 2k zero
goes into the next case
zero
followed
no that's dead
well let's watch this one anyway see
what happens this one will will take us
to this situation
beta 2 j followed preceded by 0
is dead
it falls into this pattern
and
so this
we get here and and now this is dead
this is dead so so one of these two has
to move at this point
um
either the uh
uh
this one or this one has to move so
um
if for example this one moves
all right well
we have either the one changes to a zero
or the zero changes to a one or both can
happen
um
uh but uh we can't have that neither
happen because then we'd be then the
whole thing would be dead and even
though this is dead week we can't have
it in
in this problem so we gotta have
uh so so let's suppose that that this
one changes next that this one can
change at this point so say this one can
change
well in that case then
uh
uh we could um
then we can go to beta 2j plus one
um
at which time this is dead again and
this one is still is is uh
still dead and so
um
uh again
we're faced with the same situation
either this one can change or this one
can change and uh suppose this one can
change now
well in that case uh we see
that k and j
will be stepping along just as if they
were equal
um and so that would give us a uh
that would give us a good uh
a a cycle that that looks good
all right now
um
if uh
if
uh so if if this happens all the time
uh for all for all values of k and j
that it always that always turns out
that that uh
when there's a choice between these two
these two which one can move it's always
going to be
the one um
that uh
to the right of the of the guy had just
moved the baton is always passenger if
it always happens like this for all k's
and j's then that gives us a fairly
strong condition on
our state on our state diagram so it
gives us
gives us lots of good cycles
for
whatever p is
p is some even number suppose p is 20.
uh then it says we could start out at
alpha zero
beta zero or alpha 0 beta 2 alpha 0 beta
4
up to alpha 0 beta 18 and give get and
get uh
a bunch of uh you know a whole bunch of
consequences of of what what the state
what what the states are on that thing
that's one
one possibility what's the other
possibility the other possibility is
that we would get at least for some
value of k and some value of j we'd get
to a situation
where this one
would now be followed by
where this where this zero is stuck
uh is dead when when preceded by
uh these
with when k is not equal to j
uh and in that case this one would have
to be it would have to still be movable
and it would take us to 0 alpha 2 k plus
1 0
data 2 j
zero
okay
now
um
okay so now now beta 2j is is is still
um is still uh dead in that point but
we've got now
uh uh so
so uh
um this is still stuck
um
this is still stuck the only thing that
can possibly
have changed you know see see beta 2j
followed by either zero or one is dead
so
um so uh it's
there's nothing we can do here so the
only thing that we could possibly do is
is is that go in this in this one this
is one of one of our unknown
one of our unknown cases here no i
thought no okay um if you look at the
you said zero beta two j zero is stuck
that's zero alpha two j zero is stuck if
you look at the table zero no if we go
back and look at the table on the left
don't we have the at the top you were
looking were using that to say that beta
that zero beta two j zero is stuck
actually if you
yeah
um that's that's for alpha that rule
though don't we have yeah well the cop
it's complementing the right neighbor
but these two but you have both cases
sure so it's actually i use this case in
this case instead of this case mistake
right but they're both dead so yeah
right
but uh i'm glad you're watching me
because i might make a mistake at any
time
yeah i haven't
i haven't gone anywhere from here okay
so now um
so at this point we gotta we gotta move
we've gotta move there it's the only
that's our only hope and so this this
must go to something
um like
we take the leftmost
thing that can move at all times or
something this must go to alpha 2k plus
1 bar say
before it gets stuck
and uh
okay so
so i
so let's see in that case
um
now i've got an alpha two k plus one bar
that's stuck and and
and uh so one of these two zeros has to
move again
um
all right now let's see
if it
it looks so it looks to me as though the
way to continue on hacking on this
problem
is something like this i would i would
uh
try to find property i would call this
maybe alpha 2k plus one
super one or something like this
because i'll oh if i might be able to
pursue this and go on to super two and
super three when but but i i would like
to make a a table
uh that would say um
what uh
uh something like this for the alpha
bars as well so i have some kind of a
mapping between these alphas
and that's and i try to keep deriving
properties like this
as i as i go on
so i'll know something about alpha 2 k
plus 1 bar and i'll know that there are
certain pairs of k and j for which uh
for which uh the zero these two this
two-state machine um is stuck in some
pairs for which it isn't stuck
um
so there's some
maybe number theoretic property
commentarial properties of the j and k
when j and k are equal we know that this
one isn't stuck so but how how
discriminating is it going to be um
in in one case you might think that this
second processor here has uh is just one
processor and has lots of states and
then this one gets to look at all those
states
uh and decide when it's stuck and when
it isn't
um
and uh
our reef pointed out last week that if
we had two of these two two processor
things in in a row it looked like
it was hopeless to get
much information across but yeah that's
sort of uh
where we're confronting it here
now
one thing that you might be able to
do to get be able to make more headway i
mean as long as you're going to assume
that you're always passing the baton to
the right you might as well make another
assumption and that is that with these
states that are question marks
you could assume that those are that
those are also stuck
because i mean
if you're looking at some okay some
setup where you've got it
where you've got
sequences this one can't be stuck what
this one it's kind of a ton at the left
i know because it it moves in this
pattern
if you well i'm sorry if the alpha is
only one processor it it it could it
could be stuck but if it isn't if if
there's more than one processor in here
it can't be stuck
and so if i got one if i what
oh okay
suppose there's two processors so then
one alpha two k looks like one a b
something
and in this case it moves
and in this case it it's got the one
over here or zero it doesn't know yet
which it doesn't know yet that it's time
to be stuck
okay um
how do i say it is one out when n is
large enough at least you know one of
these is going to be
more than two what ramsay otherwise from
the starting state one alpha two
two k one alpha 2 k plus 1
1 alpha 2 k
1 alpha 2 k plus 1
you couldn't hurt beta 2. i'll wait no
never mind
i was going to say you couldn't move at
all
that's what i was thinking before she's
all
i mean yeah
yeah i want to get a contradiction and
and we could get a kind but i can't
assume that this one is dead i'm afraid
i can assume however that it that it
dies out
quickly or something like that
um
let's see so let's for example uh okay
let's let's
put a put a assumption on here that one
that this goes to one alpha two k plus
one
bar i'll put one bar on and see if we
can get
one for example that it goes to some
something like that which is dead
um
that defines alpha two k plus one bar
and now
um
we we try to get some some rules of
of the game on the on the alpha bars as
well as the alphas
and and uh and then if we can that might
lead us to rules on alpha bar bars
and things like this but this is a
general idea when you're doing research
on something and you have a bunch of
cases just you know name them just give
a name to them and contin and see what
the pattern is and plunge on
hopefully you don't run out of memory
uh well
yeah that's right we we use uh you know
we we uh uh in this case it looks like
there will be a subscript in the
superscript the superscript saying how
many bars there are in the subscript
saying uh somehow where we are how many
steps we've we've taken from from
uh some starting
some starting configuration okay
the approach that
paying anneal that i took on sunday was
to assume that or to try and prove that
you couldn't have any processor that
would swallow a baton
you couldn't have any processor that
would that would swallow a baton that
would go in other words that this would
uh
how would it be
well the idea is if you have
three n processors and three two
processors or a marker and a cycle
you could put i guess four and four and
if you can show that no no pair of end
processor two processors or vice versa
can swallow baton then you could
definitely show there's a
pair of batons that can travel around
the ring
oh so you could use the swallowing
effect to construct uh
to construct a bad cycle right because
the swallowing would get rid of the
garbage or something like that well the
sense
this came from your point last week
where you said that if you had something
that was
recognizing the bad baton and stopping
it
but then you you found that it stopped
the whole machine occasionally
right
yeah
we got stuck trying to show that you
couldn't have that but have the town
swallow it
but you do have that as a result or or
that was a conjecture that was a
conjecture was a conjecture
i wonder if anyone has tried actually
constructing uh
a sequence of let's say six processes or
something
yeah i mean let's say
that was my my next question has anybody
tried that that's all that's what i was
going to try next
that's what you were going to try next
okay that's exactly what i was going to
bring up next in fact what time is it
going to be on
okay
let's uh let's talk about that for the
next uh for the next few minutes uh uh
because i got this as far i mean this is
the the next idea i had for a
theoretical approach on it and then you
know go to a computer and get some data
the computer will crank out a cycle and
you say oh yes this might i might have
been able to predict this by
by doing the okay so let's um
let's uh uh
forget this now for a time being and go
to
the uh the another problem suppose that
i was supposed that you were in the acm
programming contest that's i think
taking place today in new orleans uh
with our star programmer mike dixon and
uh
is it from today or tomorrow
yeah i think it's 20 days i think it's
today in the month
um
so uh and and you open up the problem
and it says uh
given a
a set of uh transitions um
uh corresponding to pr conflict
processing uh
configurations that can follow other
configurations in problem four
um
determine whether or not it uh satisfies
the conditions that uh
the the five conditions of problem four
namely about you know bad configurations
uh
you know we can't have to lead the good
ones and things like that so how would
we write a program that would test this
out what would be
so so you got a graph in other words
you've got you've got a graph of
configure you've got
some large number of configurations
here
and
and sometimes
it'll have several successors others
will have only one successor
maybe
everybody has to have at least one
successor you could check that pretty
easily it's not a tough program to check
so
how would we check to see whether a set
of
points and
and arrows
between configurations
uh satisfy these
these properties
well what are the properties one after
another ah
somebody have it
yeah
the first property was
at least one processor can move any
configuration that says that there's at
least one arrow coming out of every
point okay next problem when you're
reading in the rules right you can
determine that when you're reading in
the yeah
right so we we can read in these
transitions they're given to us as data
let's let's say
and we just have this
you know we figure out some kind of data
structure where we can at least test
that everybody has a has at least one
successor okay now what about the next
thing
at most one processor can move in any
good configuration
so
that tells us then that those that have
that have out degree one
could possibly be good but the others
couldn't so it gives us some some handle
on what
what might be good
um it's see there's there's always a
possibility of something like
like this
this one has only one way to go but then
this one has three
and then
but it'll eventually get to a good cycle
but here's a good here's a sequence of
four things that have only one successor
we could call those good
um so
probably two properties three each move
from good leads to another good
um
and no sequence of moves takes a bat
into itself
any cycle includes a move by each
processor let's forget about prop 35
for the time being and just check the
other properties so
the property 5 says that if there's a
cycle each processor moves on that cycle
and we haven't
in our graph we've we haven't looked at
the
that
we haven't identified these moves with
with processors you can put a color on
each
arrow or something that says which
processor it is that's moving and make
sure that every cycle has all the colors
but let's forget that problem so so now
first of all let's just check that
there's no no infinite bad bad things
what's a good algorithm for this
closure compute the transitive closure
so transitive closure of a point is
everything you can reach from from this
point and if you have any bad state one
where you can go
two or more states if you get back to
itself
okay so if so if so the transitive
closure would be the
the uh
the irreflected transit quota so we have
uh we have some we have a a rule x uh
goes to y
is then we can consider that to be a
relation this is the this is in the
graph this means the vertex x goes to y
then the constant closure x
arrow plus y means that x can go to y in
one or more steps
and uh if x
plus x
then you've got
a possible problem then x had better be
good right
okay so so if so you would you could uh
compute the transitive closure and see
and then
say that these have to all be good
uh for all the ones that do this have to
be good and this would be uh
then you just check to see that those
have all out degree
one
every vertex that
can lead to itself must have out degree
one and call those the good ones
yeah
um
well you also have to show that all
bad ones
filter into that
if it's
yeah with that let's let's say let's
take that as a suppose we suppose we
just use transit closure subroutine
maybe it's building the hardware of our
machine
transit closure taker so we got a
transit quota taken and we look at all
those that that
that can lead to themselves
and uh we
and if any of those have out degree more
than one we say
no good
yeah
every time you find a bad note
find all those that point to it and mark
them as bad wait a minute you're talking
about another i'm going to talk about
john's algorithm first
i'll get back to you
okay but
let's forget so
we got first of all this uh
this property so we've taken a transfer
for closure we look at all those that
that all the x for which this happens
and we and we know that we want all of
those to have out degree one now if they
all have out degree one
we call those the good vertices and
everything else is bad now is it true
then that there's no
cycle from a bad
uh
configuration into itself yes yes
because
by definition all the ones that could go
into itself were
were declared good
which to be understandable furthermore
in any good configuration it leads to
another good configuration is that
property true
uh
yet
i mean hold on right
we've defined all good configurations to
be all the x for which x goes to x uh
tran under the transit closure
okay yeah
is it true then that every good
configuration leads to another good
configuration we've all got out degree
one no i'll have a degree one and and
that must be
uh part of that same cycle well that
goes uh you know if x goes to x then x
is successor we'll go to x and then to
exit successor
okay
um and uh
and then uh at most one processor can
move that we already checked in a good
configuration so so that that's a that's
a working algorithm how fast is it to
take a transfer closure
because it can't be done i can support
login now or something like that and
cube fairly easily and cubed is uh
um
is to what we would use for any end that
we would ever probably expect to program
it is
by nighttime yeah i know there's there
are uh i think it's uh
yeah i think
i don't remember
n cubed over log n was was the bound at
one time
which was based on going through
log n columns at a time and
but
but uh let's see it's like shortest path
and it's it's new yeah wait a minute you
can do better yeah because you got the
uh
uh you got the matrix multiplication
machinery to use now so i think it's
like the same as matrix multiplication
so it's end of the
end of the 2.49 except that it except
that it doesn't start to help you over n
cubed and because the constant is so big
that you have to get in more than
you know 10 to the 10 to the 100th or
something before
the trade-off starts to help you but
but uh
but it is less than n n cubed yeah
because uh
because i believe that's true that the
uh
uh this uh for transitive closure
i don't remember now
it's embarrassing got the right volume
for somebody
yeah it's the same
yeah i think that's i think they they
showed that uh because you can because
you can get transitive closure by
multiplying matrices you you have a
matrix of zeros and ones and you
multiply the matrix
um
like you take a and you go to a squared
a to the fourth a to the eighth you keep
squaring the matrix and pretty soon the
uh
after log login steps it comes to the
the non-zero entries in the matrix are
the
are the elements in the transitive
closure
is
um
is what we would use for any end that we
would ever probably expect to program it
is
finite time yeah i know there's there
are uh i think it's uh
yeah i think uh i don't remember
n cubed over log n was was the bound at
one time
which was based on going through
log n columns at a time and
but
but uh let's see it's like shortest path
and it's it's yeah wait a minute you can
do better yeah because you've got the uh
you've got the matrix multiplication
machinery to use now so i think it's
like the same as matrix multiplication
so it's end of the
end of the 2.49 except that it except
that it doesn't start to help you over n
cubed and because the constant is so big
that you have to get in more than
you know 10 to the 10 to the 100th or
something before
the trade-off starts to help you but
but uh
but it is less than n n cubed yeah
because uh
because i believe that's true that the
uh
uh this uh for transitive closure
i don't remember now
it's embarrassing got a right volume for
day
you can look at it
yeah it's the same number
yeah i think that's i think they showed
that uh because you can because you can
get translated closure by multiplying
matrices you you have a matrix of zeros
and ones and you multiply the matrix
um
uh like you take a and you go to a
squared a to the fourth a to the eighth
you keep squaring the matrix and pretty
soon the uh
after log n steps it comes to the the
non-zero entries in the matrix are the
are the elements in the transitive
closure
because if there is a path
from x to y there will be a
a path that
that
is a simple path from x to y
one that doesn't use a cycle again and
then
and so the maximum
a vertex intermediate vertex more than
once and so therefore uh
there would have to be a path less than
n and so so the a to the n represents
all the paths of
of length n let's see that's not exactly
true you replace a by a
or a squared
something like that
uh n times log n times and then you get
transit closure
so so that's like matrix multiplication
um
yeah that's
completely enumerating all the possible
configurations
yeah but that's that's still n square
there's a there's a there's a better way
n is larger
much more cheaply yeah that's right
that's why i want to get
uh there's a there's a faster way so uh
what would you do everything
go through the notes pick up let's say
find the first one which you have which
has more an out degree of either zero or
uh
and zero obviously you already thrown
away but
let's have more than one yeah and find
all the notes which point to it
and recursively mark them back bad
okay of course keeping track so that you
don't go and mark and no okay so you
start off with some some
with uh with every vertex that's got out
degree more than one
and call it bad
and it's called its criticism
and call the predecessors of any bad one
bad and probably backwards remembering
not to cycle any any predecessor of a
bad is bad okay
okay so that's the the that's a marking
algorithm like in garbage collection or
something where we
where we uh have a
uh where we where we uh we have a
starting set
namely the ones that have out degree
more than one
and then we then we take all the
predecessors of our set and we keep on
going until until uh we've closed the
operation under undertaking predecessor
okay
now does that uh does that work so then
then the ones that we weren't able to
get under this operation we call it good
yeah subject to the condition there's no
changes all processes well that's yeah
property five we'll have to do later but
let's let's okay so now is this does
this one work
okay so uh first of all
in this case we you know we get a
different set of good ones than the
other
in this example for uh
um
uh we might get a different set of good
well not always
not in all the examples stuff
um
if you had a if we had a something which
which every vertex has out degree one
um
then uh
uh in in john's construction
uh you can suppose that
you know take
take something like this
in john's construction this these would
be called good but this one not because
it's not it can't lead to itself
but in our east construction everything
has uh
yeah up here
this one has this property that it it's
not part of the cycle but it yeah but it
has out degree one
and it doesn't have any
i don't think it'd be reached as the
predecessors of the bad ones bad ones
here bad guys are this and this
so so uh now let's see um
what's the next property
um if in a good configuration
you have out degree one
that's true because we ruled out all the
all the ones that violated that as our
first step to get
we start our initial
bad ones were the ones that
that uh that had at least two moves
uh every move from a good leads to a
good that was
that was the thing that we said that is
is uh if we're
if the predecessor
the predecessors of all the of all our
bads are
are bad and therefore the successors of
all our goods are good
now no sequence of moves takes a bad
configuration into itself
all we've done so far is classified into
good and bad
so we still have to have a way of
telling whether or not
um
whether or not we lost
it can't take it into itself because it
can't lead to a bad configuration it
says being correct
so so so as as we're doing this
we
we check that that the predecessors have
not already been marked
predecessor has already been marked it's
already marked as bad
then then you've got a cycle
is that correct is that true
no it doesn't work no
no no if you can make it you're working
back so you can always
okay so we started out with the bad ones
and we went to their predecessors
you can maintain a path from the bad
bad position where you started and
always check whether you are you have a
loop within that path
i started at one bad position you
started a bad position
yes maintain the list
so that when you
at every point check whether it's
already in that list
which means that if there's a loop
you'll find
so there's no loops
when i went back from one bad
configuration okay then i start with
another one
okay
and i start with another back
configuration and i start going back
from that
um
okay
all right
sort of a checking for a loop-free
property here so we we've we've
classified into good and bad
i think that classification is fine now
now let's let's let's try to let's now
let's restrict the
the graph to the to the bad
grad vertices how do we check whether
there's any cycles in that check what is
a tree
check whether it's a tree how do you
check that first search what depth first
search first search okay
one one way to do it yeah
so uh
all right
no you were supposed to take three more
minutes to solve that because we had
four minutes to go okay well so that's
uh
uh yeah depth first search is a good way
probably the best uh there's also uh
like a topological sort the same kind of
a thing you could
use the those there's two competing ways
to to check for cycle freeness one is uh
um
the depth first search
method where you keep on going down
another the other one is to keep
removing source vertices vertices that
have no no predecessor
and to and uh and put them first in this
in an ordering and you can complete the
ordering if
if and only if there's no cycles
and uh
the advantage of the depth first search
one is that it gives you the cycles very
directly the other one gives it to more
indirectly but that's yeah those are
the
so this so that gives a a linear
algorithm instead of uh
instead of uh ends
to the two plus uh
and and therefore
um
uh
uh
even um
uh hobgroft and almond would believe
that it's better
the uh there's always a question on
asymptotic methods as to whether or not
the constants are are uh so large that
they
that they would really apply to uh to
the problems
uh that we're facing in a real computer
program
but in this case it's pretty clear that
we got it not only is our algorithm
linear but it's very effective but it's
uh
it's very linear
hardly anything to do at each step
and uh
would would be able to grind out the
the
answer okay
would there be any way to do this
without enumerating all the possible
configurations
um
because
of interest um still still uh that's
right uh try to uh uh try to do it
symbolically if we can
let's
just kind of do it here
yeah
um
so the instincts are instincts are good
on this it's too bad that we haven't
solved the problem but i think we we got
uh uh
somewhere
that's that makes it uh that we that we
don't have to be embarrassed about the
about not solving the whole problem
okay so
now you've got to
fill out these forms and then thursday
is the
is the real uh
excitement for me anyway and i hope you
have fun between now and then
oh yeah one last word about this when
you're doing
problems with
with graphics uh it seems to to me that
sometimes mistakes are
are sometimes more interesting than the
real the real thing and i know that i
often hate to throw away some of the
bugs that i get because the images are
kind of
kind of
amusing to me anyway
so
if you if you want to bring in some of
the
to class on thursday uh some of the uh
things that
that that failed as you were developing
your final project uh we might
call one look at those two although we
wouldn't display those uh you can just
you know show them
you know
to people who are interested in seeing
the pretty postcards or something of the
things that of the other of the
of the flops uh
because i think graphical uh
uh bugs are are
lots of fun okay
so
foreign